bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
du 78 en direct entre 18 et 19h édition
du 10 septembre pour débuter cette
nouvelle semaine je reçois ce soir
Bernard Tabari président de la base de
loisir de Trapp bonsoir bienvenue sur ce
plateau la base de loisir va déposer
dans les prochains jours sa candidature
pour accueillir le nouveau centre
d'entraînement du PSG Bernard tari le
PSG à 5qus en Yveline c'est possible le
PSG à 5quents en ivline c'est en tout
cas une interrogation que que nous avons
euh que le psga a de son côté que nous
avons en ce qui nous concerne que nous
avons à la base de loisir dans la mesure
où euh un tel projet pose évidemment un
certain nombre de de difficultés de
d'interrogation donc rien n'est rien
n'est fait bien entendu
mais moi j'y crois oui bien sûr juste
pour faire parler de la base de loisir
de proposez on a beaucoup d'autres
sujets pour faire parler de la base de
loisir on va parler en tout cas de ce
dossier de candidature dans dans les
prochaines minutes dans la suite du 78
également la page sport comme chaque
lundi dorénavant avec Anthony RGE
bonsoir Anthony et bienvenue sur ce
plateau on va vous retrouver tout au
long de la saison pour faire le point
sur les différents clubs locaux et puis
bien sûr sur leurs résultats oui tout à
fait pour la reprise Montini s'est
incliné c'est du football féminin et
nous parlerons aussi du partenariat
entre l'OSC lancour et la jocer et enfin
de la fête du vélo à mon Contin bretenux
page sport complète à suivre au cours de
cette première partie du 78 voilà pour
l'essentiel du sommaire de cette édition
je vous propose à présent de retrouver
les titres de ce 10 septembre la
situation du logement à 50 ans en
Yveline Cécile Duflot ministre du
Logement a fait ses proposition pour
débloquer des terrains appartenant à
l'État l'occasion de se pencher sur la
réalité du logement social dans
l'agglomération une rentrée particulière
ce lundi à l'université de Versailles
SaintQuentin celle des étudiants
étrangers la vol Moné pour l'université
et d'ouvrir de plus en plus ses portes
aux étudiants venus d'ailleurs une façon
d'étendre sa popularité au-delà des
frontières vous le verrez tout à l'heure
le club de vélo de mon le Bretonneau est
le plus important club d'île-de-fance
avec 400 licenciés il a organisé sa fête
du vélo ce weekend idéal pour
remobiliser ses troupes et puis toujours
à Montini du football féminin Anthony
vous le disiezign Montaine évolu en 2e
division elles reprennent la saison par
une amère défaite à domicile face à
templemar vent de ville
les étudiants étrangers inscrits à
l'université de versailles-
saint-quontin en Eveline sont donc
officiellement rentrés ce matin en cours
depuis la semaine dernière ils suivent
différents séminaires d'intégration ils
sont en tout 93 93 c'est donc le chiffre
de cette édition le chiffre du jour
Alice Gastine Guillaume camps sont allés
à leur rencontre sur le site de Guy
encour ses étudiants nous expliquent
leur choix de venir en France dans les
ivblines et surtout de Laura
grandissante à travers le monde même de
l'Université de Versailles SaintQuentin
écoutez
Argentine Ukraine Lituanie Allemagne
Royaume-Uni c'est la rentrée pour ces
étudiants à l'université de Versailles
an certains resteront un semestre
d'autres une année les étudiants qu'on
vient d'accueillir ce sont des étudiants
qui viennent dans le cadre de programme
d'échange c'estàd des des échanges avec
des universités qui sont partenaires de
l'UVSQ les autres étudiants étrangers
viennent s'inscrire dans des diplômes
soit 95 nouveau venus sur 2400 étudiants
étrangers choix des cours ces
d'étudiants assurance maladie
l'installation peut vite se transformer
en un parcours du combattant à commencé
par la recherche d'un logement ça
difficile je suis en train de trouver un
colo une chambre je ne sais pas mais
c'est difficile pour moi les difficultés
parfois c'est la langue parce que
parfois leur niveau de français est
insuffisant pour pouvoir suivre les
cours qui sont donnés en français pour
la majorité des cas après la difficulté
majeure c'est le logement faut pas se
cacher qu'il y a quand même quelques
difficultés pour les étudiants un
logement de la même façon que pour les
étudiants français d'ailleurs mais bon
on a un service logement qui est très
actif qui est qui a été ouvert il y a
pas très très longtemps donc qui les
aide un maximum comme vous l'avez vu on
a distribué une liste pour les étudiants
qui serai en difficulté encore
aujourd'hui pour trouver un logement
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
compte 18000 étudiants et près de 1400
enseignants chercheurs elle a passé 230
accords de partenariat avec des
universités à travers le
monde pour plus d'information sur cette
rentrée sur les enjeux de l'Université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin à s'ouvrir
aux étudiants du monde entier
rendez-vous dès demain à 18h en direct
dans la nouvelle édition du 78 nous y
consacrerons une large partie on passe
au fit du jour de ce 10 septembre le PSG
va-t-il s'installé à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline c'est la question que nous
allons poser à notre
invité pour ce fait du jour Anthony vous
êtes resté en plateau avec nous dorén
avant le spécialiste sport de cette
rédaction de TV fil nous recevons
Bernard Tabari président de la base de
loisir de Saint-Quentin la base de
loisirs et candidate pour accueillir le
nouveau centre de formation du PSG le
dossier doit être déposé d'ici au 15
septembre les dirigeants souhaitent
construire sur un terrain d'une
superficie entre 30 et 50 hectar un pôle
complet pour accueillir centre de vie
des professionnels centre de formation
et l'équipe féminine plusieurs terrains
également un lieu d'hébergement pour
faire dormir les joueurs la veille des
matchs où est comment est venue cette
idée et d'où vient-elle cette idée de la
base de loisirs d'accueillir C ce
complexe immense et bien elle vient de
d'un certain nombre de gens qui
connaissent bien le PSG ses besoins
actuels et qui conna fans du PSG qui
sont d pourquoi pas la base loisir qui
connaissent également bien à la base de
loisir euh et qui savent que sur la base
de loisirs qui fait un ensemble de 600
hectares nous avons environ 70 hectares
qui sont aujourd'hui au nord de la base
de loisir et qui ne sont pas utilisés
pour l'instant dans le cadre des
missions Miss normale de la base de
loisir qui sont des missions comme son
nom l'indique de loisirs sportifs de
détente culturel et cetera ces ces
terrains sont aujourd'hui concédé à
agroparitech qui est l'égise l'école de
d'agronomie de de Grignon et qui les
utilise pour des des des cultures
agricoles que que chacun peut voir
d'ailleurs lorsqu'il vient se se
promener sur la base donc ces terrains
là effectivement sont sont ces terrains
ces terrainsl qui sont situés voilà pour
ce qui con un peu
accè de la base de loisir pas l'accès
principal derrière camping voilà et
évidemment ces terrains sont sont pour
nous un enjeu formidable pour pour
l'avenir à moyen et long terme nous
avons d'ailleurs nous sommes nous
lançons là ces jours-ci une étude un
schéma directeur global sur la base de
loisirs pour sur son son avenir à moyen
et long terme sur les les les les
grandes pistes que nous souhaitons que
nous souhaitons mettre en œuvre et le
devenir de ces terrain là
constitue évidemment un cœur un pôle
important de de ces interrogations on va
voir peut-être une vue aérienne on a vu
quelques images justement du site que
vous proposez au parisgermain pour venir
installer son camp d'éloge 2.0 on va
l'appeler comme ça nouveau centre
d'entraînement donc ça c'est la vue
globale de la base de loisir terrains
sont situés plutôt au norder un peu la
carte voilà ce sont des terrains qui
possèdent quel quels avantages et bien
plusieurs avantages les premiers c'est
qu'ils sont
plats second ont avantage important
c'est qu'ils sont ils sont reliés très
facilement très directement à un système
d'autoroute puisque nous avons au nord
leschangeur les cintinois connaissent
bien ça l' changeur dit de de Bois
d'Arcy à côté de je sais pas si on a le
droit de citer des marques commerciales
ici mais de le roi Merlin trop tard
j'allais vous dire n mais c'est trop
tard et donc cet échangeur là donne
directement sur le nord de la base de
loisir et par cet endroit-là on accède à
la nationale 12 et et et très
directement à euh la A12 la A13 et donc
le Parc des Princes
euh
le autre autre avantage de de ces
terrains euh en tout cas tel que le le
perçoivent bien euh le PSG c'est la
proximité de ces terrains avec une ville
avec un centre ville euh celui dans
lequel nous sommes ici donc la proximité
d'hébergement la proximité de commerce
la proximité d'activités culturell
c'est la proximité des gares également
pour le transport des joueurs mais aussi
des des des spectateurs éventuel et des
et des
amateurs donc ce sont là des des des
atouts particulièrement intéressants
Anthony vous iriez voir vous le PSG
s'entraîner à 50 ans d'iveline pas si
j'irais le voir mais une première
question me vient c'est est-ce que
Zlatan Ibrahimovic les cataris
viendraient à Saint-Quentin et pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas ils sont venus comment
ça s'est passé la visite justement ils
sont déjà venus voir un petit peu alors
l'encadrement du PSG le directeur
général délégué Jean-Claude Blanc et un
de ses adjoints monsieur pifre sont
venus voir début juillet les
terrains je voudrais insister sur le
fait que nous sommes pour l'instant dans
ce qu'on appelle communément une phase
exploratoire des contacts exploratoires
c'està-dire que chacun dit un petit peu
ce qu'il a ses avantages mais aussi ses
sans sans sans cacher s ses
inconvénients euh donc nous en sommes là
pour l'instant il y a vraiment aucune
décision de prise je souhaite pas qu'on
qu'on tire de de notre entretien de de
des aucune décision de prise en tout cas
on n pas eu d'information ce sens mais
alors justement le PSG s'appelle le PSG
pour le le côté Saint-Germain en lait
ici s'il vient sa-qu1 ça va être quoi le
psq psqy Paris je je laisserai au aux
fans du PSG et et àes respons parce que
derrière cette question en fait se pose
aussi véritablement le le fond de la
pensée des des Qataris qui maintenant
possèdent le PSG est-ce que
véritablement ils ont envie de quitter
Saint-Germain ha parce que
historiquement la ville est liée donc
est-ce que vous avez pas le sentiment
non plus qu'on utilise les candidatures
des autres villes alors je vais tout de
même citer il y a carrière sur scène qui
va déposer un dossier Montesson poissi
et donc Saint-Quentin Saint-Germain va
forcément vouloir garder le le centre
c'est un moyen donc pour revenir à ma
question pour les cataris de faire
pression sur Saint-Germain au lait pour
obtenir plus écoutez ça c'est une
question qu'il faut leur poser hein vous
en tout cas vous avez pas ce sentiment
là d'être utilisé un petit peu non pas
pas du tout pas du tout je je pense que
leur leur leur intérêt qu'ils ont
manifesté lorsqu'ils sont venus est tout
à fait est tout à fait sincère ils nous
ont posé c'est pour ça que je disais que
nous sommes dans une phase exploratoire
ils nous ont posé tout un tas de
questions très techniques hein depuis le
sens du vent jusqu'à la la durée du
parcours entre entre ces terrains et le
Parc des Princes bon
donc nous répondons cette semaine là à à
tous ces questionnements avant avant
d'aller plus loin euh donc après le le
le quitter Saint-Germain c'est quelque
chose qui qui les concerne à savoir puis
quitter entièrement partiellement bon
c'est peut-être quelque chose qu'il
peuvent regarder pour l'instant le PSG
est encore à Saint-Germain pour le camp
d'entraînement vous avez vu le camp des
Loges en images il y a quelques instants
alors le PSG à saquentin en iveline est
un r est- un cauchemar souhaitez-vous
que l'équipe de la capitale Vienne
s'entraîner à 50 ans en yeline c'est la
question que nous avons posée
aujourd'hui dans les rues de
l'agglomération
ça serait pas plus mal oui c'est il y a
de la verdure c'est ouais non ouais
c'est il a beaucoup de suppor dans la
région donc je pense que ça serait une
bonne chose ah ben moi je n vois aucun
inconvénient c'est leur problème et puis
je seraiis pas compte pourquoi pas ça
évitera d'aller à Paris pour aller le
voir ça sera moins compliqué bon ça
changera rien peut-être un peu plus de
tourisme les gens qui vont venir voir vu
l'information et la crise qu'on croise
actuellement avec les salaires qu'ils
ont par rapport au résultats qu'ils
obtiennent et a quand même encore aussi
là un problème voilà alors après qui
joue à à SaintQuentin ou ailleurs je
sais pas si c'est vraiment ça le
problème après bon c'est peut-être bien
aussi de d'avoir le Paris Saint-Germain
ici bon pourquoi pas si on peut faire
comment dire un exemple pour la jeunesse
et et des installations confortables
pour les
joueurs et des installations
confortables pour les
joueurs retour en plateau dès qu'on
pourra nous couper le son ça sera
beaucoup plus pratique comme ça parce
que sinon on s'entend voilà en tout cas
jusqu'à la fin de ce micro trottoir le
sentiment c'était que c'était plutôt un
rêve pour les 5tinois de venir voir
s'installer le Paris Saint-Germain il y
a une réalité tout même aussi économique
derrière et une urgence parce que les
Qataris veulent que d'ici à 2015 ce
centre soit opérationnel est-ce que ce
serait possible si 550 an Eveline était
retenu les territoires de la base de
loisir du Nord de la base de loisir
alors 2015 était effectivement un
objectif qu'ils nous ont signalé il est
clair les les expertises que nous avons
faites cet été nous montre qu'en ce qui
concerne ces terrainsl ce sera difficile
dans la mesure où effectivement nous
sommes là dans des terrains qui sont
classé en zone naturelle euh dans le
Plan Local d'Urbanisme de Montin et dans
le schéma directeur de la région
î-de-france don alors lequel est en
révision actuellement euh mais
évidemment il faudra après ajuster les
règles de ces de ces différents
documents d'urbanisme avec les besoins
euh du du du du club localement est-ce
que bon c'est clair que pour étendre des
des terrains de football ça devrait pas
poser trop de problème faire des stades
avec des tribunes c'est déjà de la
construction et puis faire un bâtiment
c'est là de la construction qui
effectivement nécessitera une évolution
des règles c'est peut-être le point noir
dans la candidature de de 50 alors c'est
en tout cas une une difficulté donc ce
sera effectivement à mettre dans la
balance chez eux je voudrais ajouter
quelque chose d'important que auquel M
fait penser c'est vos votre micro
trottoir c'est c'est effectivement
l'intérêt pour les clubs locaux euh
c'est quelque chose que nous avons
beaucoup souligné vis-àis d'eux et
qu'ils ont souligné de leur côté
également il ne s'agit absolument pas et
surtout pas de faire une enclave
totalement fermée une espèce de
forteresse dans laquelle sébrouerit
quelques dizaines de joueurs
professionnels euh de d'ussi haut niveau
soit-il euh mais il s'agit effectivement
d'avoir aussi des euh des structures qui
soient ouvertes sur les clubs locaux sur
les joueurs amateurs le PSG c'est non
seulement les professionnels que nous
connaissons bien mais c'est aussi un
centre de formation un centre de
préformation avec des dizaines et des
dizaines de jeunes de jeunes enfants
jeunes ados et cetera et ce lien là
devrait être devra être très fort si le
PSG vient chez nous la Fondation PSG
existe d'ailleurs déjà et travaille dans
ce sens et quelque fois avec les clubs
déjà de de saintquenttin en yeline même
si ils sont du côté de sa Germain merci
Bernard Tabari d'être venu sur le
plateau souhaite bonne chance avec ce
dépôt de candidature officiellement
c'est le 15 septembre la date arrêtée
puis on parle de 2 mois un mois avant
que la décision soit prise mais rien n
voilà la décision de leur côté mais la
décision de notre côté reste à prendre
également dans la mesure où le comité
syndical de la base de loisir devra bien
entendu se prononcer pour l'instant on
imagine que si le parisgermain dit oui à
Saint-Quentin du côté de la base de
loisir ça devrait quand même bien se
passer en tout cas on vous le souhaite
j'espère com Mo tout le monde sera
d'accord de ce côté-là